let's jump to this next story because
i'm um again i think this is this all
really comes together in interesting
ways from post-millennial biden to
cancel up to ten thousand dollars in
student loan debt extend payment pause
until december
and there's also going to be a twenty
thousand dollar forgiveness which i
believe is additional if you receive the
pell grant they say um
in addition pell grant recipients will
see up to 20 000 of their debt cancelled
i i read somewhere that it was actually
in addition to but i could be wrong i
think it's 10 on top of 10 is what i
learned is that what it was because
someone someone wrote it was 20 on top
of 10 and they may have been mistaken it
was it was like a mainstream publication
or something but anyway
this
ain't it
they're not actually solving the problem
of student loan debt the predatory loan
system will still exist all their all
he's basically doing is giving a tiny
bribe to people to vote for him but i
think the bigger issue here that i'm
interested to hear your thoughts on uh
uh james is
universities these these schools they
are subsidized indoctrination machines
and now people are getting a freebie so
it's like they're they're continually
subsidizing in more and more ways they
want it to be free yeah well of course
they want to be free
anybody who's sharing a cult religion
wants you to come and experience it and
if it costs money to support they want
someone else to pay for it so they can
keep funneling people in without
hindering themselves right yeah so i'm
curious what you think about all this no
i mean so this is i mean there's a whole
thing we could get into if you want to
about how universities back themselves
or paint that painted themselves into
this financial corner they're in but
with the students let me just like take
one step back and we'll come back into
focus because it's going to hit both of
the things we're just talking about are
all the things we've been talking about
the agenda behind much of leftist
activism if you read marcusa marcuzza
says in another essay it's called the sn
liberation in 1969 the first chapter of
that it's an essay but it's like 170
pages long so it's
back in the day kids we wrote real
essays
they weren't like you know
500 words
sorry op-eds it no it's 170 pages the
first chapter of his essay in liberation
is a biological foundation for socialism
and what he explains is that if you want
to get socialism you have to change the
level of people's vital needs you have
to change people in terms of what they
need now he has a footnote that says i
don't literally mean biology so he's not
literally advocating for eugenics and
every time he uses the word biological
it has quotes around it so he means
something different by it and what i
finally figured out is what he means by
it is
that you don't know how to live life
without getting your way in other words
uh psychopathology literally the
definition of psychopathology interferes
with your ability to engage in daily
life so
every bit of leftist activism that's
followed off of marcusa which is
basically all of this radical left since
the 1960s
has
at the bottom the goal to create the
activists who are going to
not be able to figure out how to live
their life without getting the policy
change that they demand so in this case
you give all these kids crazy amounts of
student debt and what do they do they
become agitators for student loan uh
forgiveness and eventually free college
because they want to have the free
indoctrination program and so hand in
glove the colleges become the
indoctrination centers or they're
actually the programming centers they're
more like maoist thought reform prisons
than they are like indoctrination so you
turn it into a thought reform prison and
you get kids to demand that it be free
because you put them in financial dire
straits now with the trans issues the
same thing because what happens if you
transition a child
put them on puberty blockers stereotypes
you cut them up sterilize them but what
else do you know how expensive you know
how many drugs and you know how much
medical care they have to take them for
an extremely long for like the rest of
your life
right right so what are those people
going to advocate for at a policy level
uh-oh
socialized medicine because the
medicine's so expensive and the system
broke them and it's so expensive so what
you're doing history uses people and
then discards them sorry trans activists
that's what you're doing you're using
these poor kids and you're going to
discard them
uses people then discards them to get
their policy agendas in place and in
this case you're going to create an army
of people among other things they're
politically moldable et cetera but you
also are going to create an army of
people who are going to advocate
vigorously for the rest of their lives
for socialized medicine
just like these kids in college what's
worrying to me about this is uh we we
talked about the d transition or
subreddit where you have nearly 40 000
people in constant posts from people
about how they're becoming suicidal
because they were rushed and didn't want
to do it yeah no kidding my whole
response to the whole thing is like
whether someone is is trans or someone
is not trans and being pressured we
better slow that thing down before
people start taking their own lives well
now you know that's what we want you
know one of the main reasons that
they're doing there there are a few but
one of the main reasons that they're
they're pushing it so hard is because
they need that army of broken people who
are going to be pharmaceutical patients
for the rest of their life who are going
to have expensive medical treatments
we're going to add ask for and beg for
socialist medicine i kind of feel that's
a bit
a bit of a stretch i think there's a lot
of factors at play there's industry
standards there are money to be made
there's money to be made but there's
money to be made in the short term too
in the long term as well but i think a
lot of these people like if you look at
the mothers who bring their kids to
these shows it's like you've got
munchausen by proxy but then you have
parents who are genuinely genuinely
confused and don't know and think
they're doing the right thing sure of
course of course i think you'll find
with most circumstances you have normal
people being pulled in a direction yes
and it's and it's a much smaller faction
that are probably nefarious no that's
exactly right as a matter of fact the
vast majority of say the so-called
parents of trans kids and i say that
so-called because i don't believe such
things
as trans kids exist um
there are people who've been pulled into
this as as you were suggesting but the
parents a lot of them were like i got a
side video there i think that's
factually incorrect uh we we talked
about there's a there's an article from
a phd professor who talks about
endocrine disruptors and hormone
disruptors okay which masculinized the
brains of female fetuses and then
resulted in trans kids i think i think
how often is that so maybe they do exist
right and that's that's one in ten
thousand one in twenty two sure i'm not
saying it's one in 10. i'm just saying
okay you know for you to say you don't
think they are they do exist
i think i think we've got i'll walk back
to the very rare very rare i agree with
and i think the the challenge is
we we have a system right now that
doesn't discern between social and the
actual oh no they're not even going to
try right
it's just
rushing kids into uh medical treatment
which is going to permanently alter and
and for many of these kids we're clearly
seeing now the detransition subreddit
ruin their lives yeah big mistake
because you dangle out
you tell them you have this huge problem
there's no real good solution to it
you're probably going to commit suicide
if you don't get resolution to it here's
this treatment that we here's this one
path out this by the way this is how
they did maoist thought reform is they
put people under outstanding
psychological pressure with a limited
set of choices for how to escape that
pressure and then they go into that and
then what happens is they get four or
five years in and then whoop the rug's
been pulled out from under them they
don't have any options to get out
anymore the underlying problem never got
treated my question is how much of this
is an emergent phenomenon versus a
directed phenomenon oh yeah well um
lots of money goes into it so there's
some directedness to it some of it
though this is what i started to say a
lot of these poor moms were were kids in
the 90s right and we all grew up if we
grew up in the 90s we all grew up with
this kind of like boogeyman of it was
real but there was this you know
character that was really heavily
portrayed as the the you know the evil
angry there's almost always an angry dad
who disowns their kids for being gay
right and everybody's like oh that guy's
terrible so you have a whole bunch of
people who grew up in the 90s who who
had this character as like the big evil
guy to think of then they grow up in
their adults now and they have their
children so what are they going to be
hyper inclusive as like an overreaction
then you add in the munchausens by proxy
which is where you know if people don't
know what munchausen's by proxy is i
know you guys do but it's where you
poison your kid so that they're like
sick and then you pick up the pity
points like oh my poor child so for
people who aren't familiar munch houses
is when you feign being sick for
attention and by proxy is when you faint
someone else being sick for attention
yeah often they did like drip feed their
kids poison and say you know sally's so
sick oh my gosh so like like it sixth
sense the the the mom yeah was poisoning
the daughter and then going my
daughter's so sick yeah i think just
wanted to kill the daughter in that
movie but um this is a really important
point too that i think argues for a
potential emergent phenomenon that we're
seeing
i've talked about this yeah the
boogeyman's grown up
when i was little we had all these signs
everywhere about how racism was bad
and so all of these millennial kids
around me grow up being told about how
awful racism is they have been trained
to combat racism the only problem is
we've enacted a bunch of policies doing
away with the institutional problems i'm
not saying it's perfect i'm not saying
it's done i'm just saying for the most
part things are pretty good you know
like things have improved dramatically
and now you have these people who grew
up on this seeking it out but they can't
find it yeah so i refer to it as an
autoimmune disorder yeah yeah of course
now it's not really a question as to
whether or not there are people are
taking advantage of this for for and
these would be nefarious people i just
think they're relatively small in number
who are pushing this uh usually with a
lot of money behind it for whatever
other ends they have and if we might
quote from the great philosophical epic
i guess legend of game of thrones chaos
as a ladder and they know that causing
these points of damage creates
opportunity now i don't think there's
terribly many of those people relatively
speaking the proportion of them might be
as small as one or two percent which by
the way matches the proportion of
psychopaths in the underlying population
i met
i knew a bunch of people from occupy
wall street i was down there for a while
and um
what i was told by some of the
organizers people with access to the
resources who knew what was going on had
plans and were controlling what was
going on they said we want to flip the
pyramid over
sounds good right
the pyramid right you got the you got
the elites on top you got the
bourgeoisie you got the proletariat yeah
so it sounds like to the the uneducated
to the unlearned oh you want to put the
working people on top to give them
control right that's what socialism
wants yeah well i'm not one of those
people i responded with if you flip a
pyramid over it's going to topple into a
brick a pile of bricks and then there's
only going to be one or two of the
working-class people on top and they're
like right that'll be us yeah exactly
they were not saying that's an
entitlement all all of the poor people
will be
on the top and all of the evil owners
will be on the bottom they were saying
once we flip it over it resettles into a
new pyramid with us on top that's right
that's right exactly and that's that
that entitlement we were talking about
previously and of course that attracts
psychopaths because they know that
there's a gigantic opportunity there and
they can create that chaos to flip the
pyramid over and arrange things so that
they end up on top of that that pile and
this is how these things always go that
i mean the bolshevik revolution didn't
create uh you know this new paradise
society
made a very very very small like
hyper-feudal society with a very small
number of lords in the communist party
you know i describe it monopolization of
power centralization of power is bad
we have anti-trust laws because we're
like this company got too big okay
communism socialism and any kind of
authoritarian government system
skips the process by which power
coalesces and just instantly snaps it
all right to the center yeah okay that's
not good that creates problems and
it turns out that the people it puts in
charge are people who are good at
accumulating power they're not people
who know how to do anything they're just
people are good at accumulating power
and maintaining power like i learned
recently i was talking with a woman from
she grew up in the soviet union and uh
her family was was fortunate enough to
survive and it fell and then they came
to america in the in the 90s and um
she was saying do you know why they made
us wait in breadlines it wasn't because
they could have set up more breadlines
it's like literally nobody had anything
to do
it wasn't that it was that if you waited
four to five to six hours
in line for for your ability to eat
dinner that night you weren't doing
anything else right you couldn't go do
something else i saw a really
interesting meme someone posted about i
remember where i saw it they posted
about how when they were when they were
younger and in school
the teacher
they were learning they were in the
history lesson and the teacher all of a
sudden snapped at one of the students
and accused them of breaking some rule
they clearly did not break like you were
you're speaking loudly go to the
principal's office and then when the
student was like no i wasn't the teacher
said does anybody else want to back him
up
anybody else want to want to put their
name in that and go to the principal's
office office with him defend him and
none of the kids said anything and she
goes okay pack your things go see that's
what they say as soon as he left she
said i know he didn't do anything wrong
but none of you would actually call out
the fact because the authority told you
and you were scared i'm glad that she
made that point because that's why they
say that the the first person to stand
up is i mean it does take courage but
they're not the one who has the most
courage it's the second person who
stands up because they know what they're
in for
that takes the most courage and then
once you get over that hump the third
person that takes less the fourth person
who takes less and on and on and on and
that's how that's how courage actually
works in a lot of ways that's how i feel
about margaret taylor green i feel like
she's a target for the swannings because
she is the one introducing legislation
like she wants to declare james revenge
and ruth sent us which docks the uh the
addresses of the supreme court justices
she wants to have him declared a
terrorist organization this bill is not
likely to pass she does have co-sponsors
but it takes the people who are starting
to
make this part of their central platform
she is very brave but we need more
people to follow suit and that takes a
tremendous amount of courage i don't
think you can in the united states
declare an organization a terrorist
organization she has a bill in congress
for it but i just think ultimately it
just fails because it's the first
amendment issue you can you can charge
someone with terroristic acts specific
things
and what which is what you would need to
do so she would need to file uh
um what is it
a referral for it to the doj on these
people for the crimes committed however
kind of pointless because the doj knows
they're doing these things and you know
i'll mention this too
there are similarities to what happened
to marjorie taylor green what happened
to us there are some similarities i'm
not going to get into security because
there's an act of investigation in
multiple jurisdictions but um it was the
day after marjorie taylor green was here
that we got sweated the first time
these people have not been brought to
justice but there are as i mentioned
multiple jurisdictions multiple
jurisdictions looking into it i've you
know given several statements and
evidence so it may be moving forward but
we're going on now seven and a half
months it was january 6 when we got
swatted
now it seems like it may be the same
person or a similar entity going after
marjorie taylor green
where is the is the doj
they are they unable because if they're
unable then we've got a very serious
stability problem in this country if
people can keep doing this yeah
and people know that this is how this
works the people that game the system
that you were talking about they know
how to gain into system they know that
the system can drag things out that they
can drag their feet on whatever and they
can create that repressive situation
where one side's strongly favored versus
the other
by dragging it out when it's one side
and not dragging it out acting quickly
when it's the other side the fbi would
not investigate hunter biden but they're
jumping at the chance to go raid trump's
house yeah exactly exactly what i'm
talking about it's exactly right and
right right before the midterm too no
we're not going to interfere in an
election oh the midterms coming up rate
trump yep exactly amazing and now now
there's a lot of fears there's there's
been talk about whether or not trump
would be willing to make you know
announce his run right before because of
what will happen with the republican
party and the fact that he's been raided
by the by the fba will make him look bad
and now there's questions being raised i
think trump should just announce i think
we saw from the from the elections the
other day that the gop desperately needs
trump to be actively involved and trump
should not wait he should just come out
and be like yo we're going to run and
we're gonna start endorsing people i
mean he's been endorsing people and his
record is here's i'll say this in 2018
trump's endorsements were like 50
something percent
in 2020 it was 70 something percent so
far right now trump said like 99 i think
is it like 99
success over 90. overnight it's i think
it's 99 yeah and so
the suggestion is
republicans lost in 2018
republicans made massive gains upsetting
what was projected in 2020 and with
trump's you know recogni uh endorsements
this successful
people are thinking that's an indicator
that republicans are going to win but
we'll see man the democrats uh there was
a swing district new york 19
was predicted to go republican it's an r
plus the three district democrat one
so i don't i don't you know people
mentioned myra flores in texas as like
oh red waves coming because a republican
won a democrat district and i'm like
dude the whole thing's flipped over on
its head we don't know what's gonna
happen i think in some ways that's what
the student loan debt reminds me of like
this is a bid from biden's
administration to be like remember
democrats are good the democrats give
you things before midterms and it's just
not quite as successful as they want to
be i would think and i'm not an expert
in this that if you really wanted to
address the student loan debt problem
you'd make it easier to declare
bankruptcy on student loans because it's
almost impossible right now and that is
trapping people in debt that you
wouldn't carry except for the fact that
you are told you have to go to college
to advance to get a better career it tru
it saddles them with debt immediately
while pushing them down a path that is
not giving them any financial success i
think we should uh
forgive interest on all the loans and
apply any interest payments made
directly to the principal but you got to
pay back the principal
that's probably right you got money you
got to pay it the system itself is
predatory and uh the first thing you got
to do here's step one here's the
solution to the student debt crisis for
all the left and the right fans out
there
um first end the loan system it's
clearly predatory all of the left
clearly agrees right they tricked you
into getting these loans they're too
expensive you can't pay them back all
right end it
now for everybody's holding debt
interest payments
done no more interest any payment you've
made
that interest will be credited towards
the principal you got to pay back what
you were given but not the interest this
is the best part people get their
student loan forgiveness if you got
money you got to pay it back now if you
paid more in interest than you borrowed
we applied that as a tax credit on your
your taxes for this year and it rolls
over until gone so if you pay 10k in
interest beyond the principal
then this year that 10k goes towards
what you would have paid in taxes so
it's a it's a big win for all of these
student debt forgiveness people right
but if you were given five grand and you
bought cheeseburgers and beer with it
and then you paid back half will forgive
the interest and if it's still a
thousand bucks left over you've got to
pay that principal but the first thing
ending the system of loans
seriously hinders
the the educational institutions
puts us
a big slow down on that and will help
restore to only the people who truly can
and want to go to college do
if you want to get a private loan you
know from a bank or something to go to
college that's fine you can do that but
the way it's set up right now with these
these these these uh federalized loans
and grants and things no not get rid of
all that i mean the academic
institutions are
i'm sure we're all fine with this but
they're not going to come out well from
this and the reason that these loans are
the way that they are is because the
academic institutions got walked not
just the students get walked down to
primrose path if you have to go to
college you have to if you want to get a
good job the whole thing the
institutions themselves did too when
when the federal underwriting of student
loans came in in the 90s
they saw this gigantic opportunity to
you know compete for students that they
didn't have before and this is when you
saw this massive shift towards student
services take place in the universities
so they're building rec centers they're
building bowling alleys they're building
movie theaters they're building fancy
new dorms like my dorm was like
literally
designed by a prison designer and it was
about 50 rooms for one bathroom you know
we all shared a shower when the janitors
got mad because one guy like went to the
bathroom in the heater in the in the in
the bathroom so he got pissed and he
took away all of our shower curtains so
we all just had to like shower like
here we are yeah because it was like
that was back in the day man um
things were different back in the day so
they started building all these cool new
dorms and all this other stuff and they
got massively massively in debt hundreds
of thou hundreds of millions of dollars
in mortgage debt and so these
the the the strings we're talking about
the loans being given to the students
but there's massive loans that were
given to the institutions too and then
they were using the loans being given to
the students to try to pay off those
debts themselves now what is happening
the same financial institutions are
playing this esg game
the social part of esg that's
environmental social governance that's
the s and the governance is that you
have to have the right people in places
of power and offices and say diversity
deans and things like that if you want
to have a good score to have your your
finances managed by these exact same
financial institutions then what do you
have to do the same ones by the way
you're going after with occupy that were
too big to fail turns out they learned
that they were too big to fail and could
do whatever they wanted because they got
bailed out well what are they doing
they're now saddling these universities
with insane administrative bloat so they
can't possibly pay their debts either so
what we're seeing is a recreation of the
company town but the financial industry
is the company and basically every large
institution is the town and then people
that are taking these student loans are
just getting roped in for it i feel like
the end result to all of this is not
going to be what what these woke people
think no obviously not it's an absurd
concept but the end result is these big
institutions that they're bloating are
just going to crumble in on themselves
they have to in the end and and you know
what would you do if you had
say this huge
institution like the entire financial
system of the world that's likely to
collapse in on itself and it's
leveraging everybody's pension funds to
be able to do it and what so those are
all are going to be what's going to
collapse what would you work like hell
to put in place if you could before the
big collapse comes why not a gigantic
social control system like surveillance
and social credit systems and all of
this to protect yourself so that you
don't end up like swinging from a lamp
post when everybody's really really
really mad that you wrecked the whole
world's economy thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you